we are always given the same blow
moreover with this chosen immigration
forgetting to say that it does not cancel
the immigration suffered
it accumulates with the immigration undergone
that it will continue
I've been doing it for years
that I notice
that hundreds of thousands are brought in
it's not even millions
of people on the territory
and I don't have the feeling
that these labor shortages were alleviated
far from it
she even has in a certain way
the inactivity rate
because I remind you of this
these are figures from the ministry
of the interior dating from 2020
the rate about
twice as much unemployment
for persons of foreign nationality
that among people of French nationality
who are resident in France
and there is
would only be what
for people of Algerian nationality
about 41 6 inactivity rate
so we can see that in fact
this idea this illusion that a migration
of work would fill the gaps
particularly in the catering system
is a lie and a fatal mistake
all the more serious as we remain in this logic
I find it dramatic
a downward spiral in wages
since we can see that the idea behind
is to not especially
not seek to raise wages
so that the French can
live with dignity from this work
and therefore apply
but
go looking for a rather connoted term
a reserve army
here it is and I think that
with regard to purchasing power difficulties
of the French currently
we'd better bend over
on the question of how
we give back purchasing power to the French
through salaries
particularly through the reduction in expenses